welcome to council of geeks my name is
nathaniel wayne and you are joining us
for the largest round table that we have
attempted i'm joined as i have been
previously by ryan daly paul scavito we
also now have jason sharer joining us as
well
and we have all just gone and seen
avengers age of ultron we came we saw
did we enjoy
first impression it was very
entertaining i started off enjoying it
from the first minute and i never
stopped enjoying it and i found myself
as i was watching it liking each
individual scene
more than any individual scene from the
first one but taken as a whole it felt
really big and not necessarily cohesive
i don't know how long the original cut
is moving the original cut was over
three hours so that's the thing this is
220. i want to see the three-hour
version of i do too yeah i really do too
because i i enjoyed it and i did like it
but a lot of the scene transitions were
very jumpy you can sort of feel the
pieces missing not in a it doesn't make
sense way but in a
i'm sure there's a cut where there had
where that had more room to breathe or
there was a smoother transition yeah it
doesn't come together as a whole for me
in that
i think it's fairly obvious at this
point that marvel i think has a standard
second unit
that is doing all of the action
direction because i could see
some very big
differences in style where i could see
shots and i'm like oh that has whedon
written all over the shop the way he's
doing this particular shot but then
there were other parts of the action
scenes that were just shot incredibly
generically um there were scenes that i
did like um
i was actually bored
through chunks of the film and i would
say it had major problems with pacing i
think for the first time i would argue
the cast of characters was too large i
felt that the action sequences were fun
i felt like the draws between them were
way too long this was not something i
felt in the first film
was that i felt like the first film was
perfectly balanced well let me ask you
guys a general question but we get two
characters who we get major backstory
for
were those backstories necessary did
they deepen our understanding of the
characters in a way that
made us more sympathetic towards them
we're talking about black widow and
hawkeye yes okay in the case of black
widow no in the case of hawkeye yes
but i don't know if that's prejudicial
just because i know more of black
widow's backstory just being a fan of
the comic books so what they had to tell
me about black widow's backstory i kind
of already knew
whereas what they showed me about
hawkeye's backstory it was stuff that i
did not expect and caught me off guard
so
so i'm more favorable to that
i think the exact opposite um reaction
to those backstories wow
during um black widow's backstory i was
deeply enthralled her in in her story
but the thing is i don't know hawkeyes
either the backstory that they gave him
was
unique to the film in that it was not
that was that has never been established
in the mainstream marvel universe okay
it was sort of very briefly touched on
in the ultimate marvel universe of the
ultimate comics it felt like
oh so now they're going to fix
the fact that they didn't sort of
develop hawkeye in the first movie
this is our scene for developing hawkeye
in this movie
i i won't argue that that was the intent
i will argue that for me at least it
worked
as blatant as that intent was hawkeye i
i liked fleshing him out i just i like
spending more time with him because he
is
the most human
on this team of gods and monsters i felt
like that the scenes with him were
examples of now we need to say something
important
and the character is going to say
something important and another
character is going to go
and there was one moment where it did
feel like
where i thought the film stopped
and it's when we introduce another
character which is that official can we
talk about him without i'm assuming
you're talking about vision yes he he
got his own character poster
yeah which actually i'll just before we
get into him i wish i hadn't known he
was in the film it doesn't wreck the
film that i knew going in but i just i
remember they're sitting wishing i wish
that it was slowly dawning on me what
this was as opposed to realizing
immediately
as soon as the pieces started coming
together on that character and i by
blame marketing on that one he's
introduced late in the game
and for a while it feels like he's it's
going to be his movie for act three yeah
and that that's actually part of my
problem with the movie is that and we
talked about this with the first film
was sort of whose film was it um and
there were times during this one where i
felt like the narrative like literally
jumped tracks and we were suddenly in
different characters movies and were
like we were like this is hawkeye's film
now and then this is um tony's film and
i i think part of that might have to do
with there were people held on to their
own agendas for a lot longer in this
film versus the first one
what did everyone think of ultron i i
want to go into this a little more
detail a little later as to why
there were moments where i actually
hated this character
there were moments i really liked him um
and i but i i actually liked him a lot
but i really felt kind of the weight of
stuff that we were missing
there's a lot of implied sort of
connection that he has with other
certain characters that feels like i'm
missing the development of that but they
try and pay it off anyways yeah yeah and
so like i i'm seeing holes in the way
the characters presented but i still
liked it but i mean it's like one of the
great things i that i like about ultron
is you see him
lose it on occasion you know he's
holding it together and he loses it and
and he just acts out of anger you know
which is not something that you expect a
robot to do to like lose its temper he
was established very quickly that i get
okay yeah artificial intelligence bad
guy i get that that's pretty easy it's
been done before
then i felt like progressively his plot
got more complicated than it needed to
be in order to introduce other elements
of the film but he does have some of
those moments of anger he does have that
so he's obviously not operating just on
this is a cold emotionless calculation
humans are the problem i will wipe out
the humans thing right and so whenever
he did parts of his plan that
maybe didn't seem like the most
efficient thing to do there's a part of
me that went
you're doing it because you think it's
slightly more elegant arrogant way of
going about it that i could i could buy
this kind of character doing who did you
feel like was the mvp of this movie i'm
gonna give it to chris evans in this one
i really liked his development as a
character in winter soldier
and that development carries through in
this film it's like he wants to get back
to where he was
but he also recognizes the impossibility
of it it's like look i know this is an
impossible dream but i'm still going to
chase it anyway because what the hell
else am i going to do
i think mvp for me i'm going to be
specific about this was hulk and with
all due respect to him not mark ruffalo
but actually hulk
and for no other reason than we got to
see him truly
rage absolutely you know and i don't
know why nathaniel but you and i are
just gonna have to
not see how to eye in this one and so
the thing is is that i give it to mark
ruffalo because my favorite moments in
the film
um
really came from mark i'm gonna go with
hawkeye for this one um okay i i felt
like
joss made amends in how
it was used in the first one he got some
of the best lines he got more character
development than any of the other
characters now most of the other
characters have their own film
franchises yeah i can explore that all
the new characters
really impressed me and i wanted to see
more of them well so it seems like sort
of the sum up is we've got three not as
good as the first one but still fun and
one
had had some big issues is that is that
a fair assessment that is fair i think
we'll we'll end on that note and uh you
can join us uh again for the
spoiler-filled commentary which will no
doubt go on for about 75 hours yeah so
come on back for that if you feel like
it until next time this council is
adjourned